[Music]
megan mccain officially joins the view
as the show's conservative voice please
welcome our new co-host megan mccain and
it was an emotional first day for the 32
year old I can't believe I'm freaking
crying already
Megan reached out for sunny Hostin hand
when the hot topics turned to her father
Senator John McCain stage four brain
cancer I haven't talked about it yet and
I knew this would be hard when you hear
cancer a nuclear explosion goes off in
your life no matter who you are it is
the most difficult thing I've ever done
in my entire life
Megan says she's committed to making it
her life mission to find a cure the
purpose of my life was political but I
actually think now it is helping
bringing awareness to brain cancer I
think that's going to be my life's
purpose meanwhile her father was
watching and tweeted his support I think
they have the the tweet but he said
watching Megan McCain's first day on the
view ABC we are very proud Megan who's
been appearing on the ABC Morning Show
for years
credits Whoopi Goldberg with encouraging
her to take a permanent seat at the
table you are such a supporter of women
and young women you've always been so
amazing to me which is why I was
comfortable coming you're the mentor and
you know first lady of the view and I
think it's incredible that you've been
so amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
you